on tuesday night deshaun watson posted a
cryptic
tweet on his account some things never
changed that was the same night
that word emerged that the texans would
be hiring
former patriots director of player
personnel nick casario to be the new
general manager the tweet lingered for a
while it was deleted the next day there
was some speculation
that watson was actually talking about
the decision from earlier in the day on
tuesday
by authorities in wisconsin to not
charge the police officers
who shot jacob blake back in august
adam schefter reported last night that
desean watson was indeed referring to
the nick casario hire and that was one
of the final
nails in a development that really began
yesterday morning peter between our show
and the taping of
our our pix podcast i had posted
something that i had been hearing and
once i start hearing things from
different people that i know
who are in different areas of the
broader nfl universe
i start to take it very seriously and
the chatter was out there that desean
watson's been telling his teammates that
he wants out of houston and once we put
that out there and we couched it
accurately and appropriately based upon
what we knew the avalanche began
ian rappaport tweeted that desean watson
is extremely unhappy with the team he
didn't tweet it he has an article i
think about it
extremely unhappy with the team and
wasn't consulted in the hiring of nick
casario they can't get him on the phone
albert breer of si.com reported that
that desean watson advocated for the
hiring of eric b enemy the chief's
offensive coordinator and they've told
desean watson he's going to have a voice
in this process
and they didn't even interview eric the
enemy
this thing is falling apart quickly for
the houston texans
and look they they
leaked yesterday to john mcclane of the
houston chronicle under no circumstances
will they trade deshaun watson
well you better fix the relationship
then if you're not going to trade the
guy
you'd better figure out how to make him
happy and job number one in that regard
is get him to answer the phone
that's how bad it's gotten and if they
don't repair that
relationship i think worse than trading
him
is having a guy at the most important
position on the roster
that doesn't want to be there
mike about a week or so ago
someone who is in the job searching
vein uh on on the part of
a team you know a team with openings
said to me you know this is like the
best year
to go look for coaches and it's the
worst year
because you can't interview him in
person
but but he said the benefit of not
interviewing him in person
is that it's so much easier
and less labor-intensive to interview
somebody
on zoom you know on a video conference
and then to sort of pair the field
and then understand that you know okay
this is the person we need to
investigate more
or this is the person and we're not
really that interested
and so and all these teams look arthur
smith is supposed to be interviewed by
all six teams
the tennessee offensive coordinator all
six available
franchises with a coaching opening and
here's my question
okay how much how difficult would it be
when you know your quarterback above all
the candidates out there
wants eric b enemy to be his coach when
you know
that that is the case or at the very
least he really likes eric b
enemy because of what his good buddy
patrick mahomes
has told him about eric b enemy and
how easy would it be to put in a request
to interview eric b enemy
whether for some idiotic reason
and i mean idiotic you have no interest
in talking to eric b enemy
which is just foolish okay
but if you whether you have interest in
him or not serious interest in
how difficult is it for your four
decision makers to sit around a table
and go on a computer screen and say hey
coach be enemy thanks for giving us a
couple hours of your time
okay how difficult would it be
and then to say hey look um
deshawn this is why we like
um arthur smith over eric b enemy and
lay it out to him
and and and all that or you know maybe
even allow
desean watson to see all of to be a
silent partner and to sit in on the zoom
calls
what's wrong with that but but be that
as it may
i cannot believe if it's true and
thus it has been written that they have
not requested permission to talk to eric
b enemy i think it's
in many ways it's just foolish you know
i was on dan patrick yesterday after
the the rumor report whatever that we
had yesterday that really lit the fuse
on this
and he and i were having this
conversation and and he he made the
point that you made even if you're not
going to hire the guy what's the harm in
talking to him it's almost like the old
al davis
talk to anybody to pick brains find out
what the chiefs think of your defensive
personnel
if nothing else the guy thinks it's a
real interview
it doesn't have to be you can talk to
him and you can find out what he knows
what he doesn't know what he thinks what
he believes and it can help you going
forward
i think in a weird sort of clumsy
current
houston texans culture way
they thought that it's easier to not
interview him at all than to do the
dance
and not finish the deal and so if we
don't interview him
well oh we've got other candidates
desean sorry we've we've hired a search
firm that has lined up these candidates
and cal mcnair has all of these other
advisors who he's consulting with and
we've come up with the candidates
through that process so we hope you can
respect that process oh yeah i know we
told you
you would have a voice in this but
there's a point where you don't
i mean that that's uh just a weird
awkward
quintessential houston texans approach
based on the overall dysfunction that
seems to be permeating the organization
and
peter i'm going to rewind a couple of
weeks ago when it came out
that cal mcnair had an informal
committee of advisors
and then i i asked some questions of the
texans for clarification
and i was told it's not really a
committee he's just talking to these
folks individually
this is a guy who's going to do what
he's going to do and no one's going to
tell him what to do other than what he
wants to do
and when you have this broad range of
different people you're talking to what
that means is
you're going to keep talking to people
until someone tells you that you should
do the thing you already want to do
he's going to do the thing he already
wants to do as influenced by
jack easterby because there's a story to
be told si.com had a great article
delving into the nooks and crannies of
this strange
power grab that jack easter b has
managed to accomplish in houston and
this hypnosis almost
that he has utilized over cal mcnair
there's a story out there as to how
easter bee got cal mcnair
to hire a general manager who wasn't on
the list of finalists
as generated by the search firm
to which cal mcnair is paying somewhere
between 100 000 and a million dollars
for their input and if
if eric b enemy isn't a finalist
it's because i believe jack easter be
convinced cal mcnair to not make him a
finalist
and the other thing rattling around in
my brain on this and i saw the tweet
last night
from ryan clark former steelers
great who's now with espn this is the
team that gave us we can't have the
inmates running the asylum
and this is the this is the team
right it's the son of the man who said
it who's now running that team
i do you want to give your your
quarterback
that kind of power and that kind of
authority over your major decisions
i can't help but keep thinking about
that line
as it relates to making desean watson
think
he has a seat at the table and then
ignoring
what he would bring to the table
it's incredible that we're saying this
in 2011 or that
i am saying this in 2011.
but yes it is because that means we have
a time machine that takes us back 10
years
it's 20 21. well hey listen listen this
time machine
should be taking us back to 1971 quite
honestly
that's what it should be but it's
incredible that in 2011
i'm making this statement the nfl is
going to have a problem on its hands
if one of these six teams does not hire
eric b enemy
that's the first statement the second
statement i believe that the houston
texans internally
are going to have a big problem on their
hands with their biggest
player if one of the people who they
hire
either for coach or gm isn't
african-american
and so the gm is done and now what about
the coach
and so i'm just saying that
uh if you i don't know maybe it was a
month ago mike i forget
how long ago it was but i had troy
vincent the nfl's evp of football
operations
on my podcast and
troy vincent was
impassioned and angry and wounded
about the fact that in 2003
to open 2003 the year the rooney rule
was adopted
there were three african-american head
coaches on opening day
in 2020 in year
17 of the rooney rule on opening day
there were three african-american
coaches in the nfl
and look this is this is going to become
in this day and age a gigantic problem
for the nfl
if something significant in this
postseason
is not done on the general manager and
coach level
uh to bring in more minority candidates
yeah and i agree with you completely and
eric b enemy has been standing on the
doorstep
for multiple years now he's in the spot
that launched doug peterson
who won a super bowl and then was in the
playoffs the next two years
the spot that launched matt nagy who's
been to the playoffs two out of three
years
eric b enemy has been the only offensive
coordinator of patrick mahomes as a
starting quarterback
and he can't get hired and i agree with
you if someone doesn't hire him
there will be an enormous and
justifiable
reaction uh but the fact that they
slammed the door in the enemy's face in
houston
where you have a quarterback who
advocated the enemy who was led to
believe he was going to have influence
over the process and they won't even
talk to the guy
that he's recommending that you talk to
that's why he's not answering the calls
that's why
he's telling teammates he's going to ask
for a trade and that's why
he just might do it i mean i think that
at one level telling the teammates you
may ask for a trade
is calculated to get the word back to
management
that they better get their act or
another word that ends with t
together quickly and take care of
deshaun watson and make him happy
this is their chance right this is this
is their chance peter
don't make me laugh i'm trying to
deliver a serious point this is their
chance to fix it they've got to fix it
and again the texans as i think i think
shireen williams
made this observation last night on our
pft writers text chain the texans have
become what the browns were a few years
ago
they cannot get out of their own way
here's the thing mike you know desean
watson
this year
had really one of the most remarkable
years in the nfl of any single player
everybody said well they were four and
12. what what they stunk
what do you mean remarkable year you
know he threw for more yards than
anybody in the nfl
he had the highest yards per attempt by
a mile
of anybody in the nfl and a lot of times
the connotation there is
well he's a bombs away guys throwing a
lot of picks he had the second highest
quarterback rating in the nfl this year
to only aaron rodgers
so look this guy on by any measure
is a top five quarterback in the nfl and
i'll tell you the other reason
why his season was vastly
underappreciated he plays without
deandre hopkins for the entire year
so then his now his number one receiver
becomes
will fuller he plays without will fuller
for five games
this year because he messes up so
he basically plays the end of this
season
you know without any of the receivers
that he thought at the beginning of the
year
or early in the off-season would be his
primary guys
and he does great now look brandon cooks
is a very good nfl receiver so
i give him that but the two best guys he
had that he thought he would have
neither of them are there as he's trying
to you know
win games late in the year and so to me
i i don't care what happens in this
whole thing i don't care
i'm not listening to anybody i am not
listening to anybody
if you if you start the conversation
with we'll give you our next five ones
then i might listen but other than that
you
do not make deals for
25 year old starting quarterbacks
who unless they get in a car accident
are going to be in the hall of fame one
day you don't do it you don't
trade those guys away so what you said
at the beginning
find a way to make peace with this guy
because he is your
best option to get out of this sinkhole
that you're in
we saw two years ago antonio brown tweet
and instagram his way out of pittsburgh
we saw last year stefan diggs with one
very well timed tweet get his way out of
minnesota
we have never seen and this is an
indictment of the texans peter
because you make your franchise
quarterback happy it's a given
it's presumed it's automatic it's like
breathing for an nfl team
you make your franchise quarterback
happy we've never seen
a franchise quarterback in his prime
say i don't want to be here anymore
and if he says that publicly and i think
he has the demeanor and the voice to
pull it off
without people lining up and pointing at
him and calling him selfish and no good
and this and that and the other thing
if he says i don't want to be here
anymore what are you going to do
once he crosses that rubicon what are
you going to do if you're the texans at
that point
your best move is to strike the best
deal you can and shame on you
for even letting it get to the point
where we're having the conversation
we shouldn't even be having the
conversation houston texans that's how
messed up you are right now as an
organization
and i have strong feelings about the
role that jack easterby's had
this is what you get when you put
someone who
isn't qualified in charge of your team
when there are so many candidates out
there with the other 31 franchises
who are qualified to properly run
an nfl franchise and know how to
communicate
properly not with this over-the-top
fluff
i'll come on slap you on the back and
make you feel good and talk fast
no you got to have people who know what
they're doing and this is the product
the fact that we are where we are
right now is evidence that the texans
don't know how to run their team or
deshaun watson wouldn't be thinking
about asking for a trade
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports